now over more than three months of
confrontations Street protests and
sometimes very blatant violence I said
previously that the forces under extreme
pressure okay so my support for the
forces because it is an important law
enforcement agency that helps us to say
that the rule of law but that doesn't
mean that I would condone irregularities
or wrong practices done by the police
force otherwise there would not have to
be all these institutions like the
capital and the IPCC to look into
complaints about individual offices and
on this occasion because of the severity
of the protests and the incidents the
IPCC has taken the initiative with my
full support to undertake a thematic
fact-finding study to assess several
important incidents and to come up with
recommendations but it would be very
difficult for me as a chief executive to
offer my own opinion on individual video
footage or shots to determine what is
right what is wrong what is true what is
fake because there there has been so far
always different versions to the same
incident so my my advice and my appeal
is for those affected individuals to
come forward to provide a side of a
story and to be undertaken in a fair and
impartial manner for example if there is
a complaint to IPCC also Capel I
understand that IPCC in addition to
their members of the Council
they have about hundred of service who
will be invited to join the interviews
all these
occasions to look at videos in order to
form a more impartial view of what has
taken place we have to put our trust in
these important institutions which have
kept Hongkong going for so many years I
know the level of mutual trust is now
relatively low in Hong Kong but we have
to make sure that we can continue to
operate as a civil society and so these
institutions will continue to play a
very important part in that particular
respect the fact that after all of over
three months we have not seen major
fatalities in Hong Kong is by world
standard because I've been meeting
overseas dignitaries and senior
officials is quite remarkable you'll ask
me when that sort of restrained her will
will disappear I really can't help you
because it is really on the ground it is
not for me it's sort of quite far away
from the commander and to be able to
judge let alone to tell them what to do
we have to trust the force and the
commanders in dealing with such a
difficult situation